what if an actor has trouble remembering
lines
what's the best way to do memorization
exercises
well i think that the last thing that i
would recommend is to
try and memorize lines is you know
script analyze the scene and understand
the script analysis of the scene in a
deep
emotional way inside of you and what i
mean by that if you look at the scene
you know who's this character and what
do they want and what are the obstacles
and what are they doing
and how's the place feeding them and are
there any objects and
you know line by line the intention and
i think if you get
clear about all that the lines just come
to you
it's not about taking the line it's
about
and making the lines yours by
improvising them paraphrasing them
there's a slew of different things
that you can do i mean one of the things
that i do is after i've done all that
work
is and i think there's an app somewhere
that does that is
actually pretty sure there is and that
you record
the line of the other character and then
you leave a space for your line
and because you know you're responding
to what somebody else is saying and it's
giving birth to something that you're
doing
so yeah
you